[Música]
olá pessoal um dia é com muita alegria
que eu estou aqui hoje vai ser um prazer
contar um pouco da minha história e
falar um pouquinho sobre a contribuição
genética para o transtorno do espectro
do autismo
então como eu cheguei ao transtorno do
espectro do autismo
eu era uma cientista que estava
completamente desanimada a fazer ciência
básica não que ela fosse que não seja
importante fazer ciência básica no nosso
país mas sim era bastante importante
fazer ciência básica mas eu queria mais
eu tinha alargado o meu primeiro pós doc
e tava trabalhando num projeto social na
periferia de são paulo
no jardim ângela e eu trabalhava com
pessoas usando lixo como forma de ganhar
dinheiro então assim eu já tinha feito
toda uma carreira acadêmica mas eu não
estava satisfeita eu fui trabalhar na
periferia com uma ação social e nesse
momento eu pensei avaliei tudo que eu
tinha feito na minha vida
falei não eu tenho uma vivência muito
boa na academia eu preciso de alguma
forma fazer algo que seja positivo para
a sociedade dentro dos conhecimentos que
eu tenho então uma professora
recém-contratada na universidade me
chamou pra montar um laboratório falou
pra mim olha tá bem é é alinhado com
aquilo que você deseja fazer porque a
gente tem uma causa que era o autismo
confesso que naquele momento não
conhecia nada do autismo
há 12 anos atrás 11 anos atrás
o autismo não era divulgado e nem era
difundido como é hoje né então hoje a
gente conhece é mais divulgado
aí eu falei bom se tem algo que eu possa
trazer de retorno para a sociedade
eu vou aí embarquei nessa
viagem há dez anos atrás
e confesso que pra mim foi uma
experiência magnífica e o mais
interessante é que recrutar os pacientes
eu fiz uma parceria com um médico e ele
disse pra mim se você quer trabalhar com
células de autistas
você vai ter que conhecer os autistas
então eu uma pessoa que trabalhava entre
quatro paredes num laboratório sair pra
conhecer os indivíduos que tinham
autismo e aí fiquei mais ainda empolgado
em começar esse projeto
então hoje nós sabemos que um em 59
indivíduo em crianças com 8 anos de
idades têm autismo nos estados unidos
de acordo com o centro de controle e
prevenção de doenças e dentro desse
número existe uma proporção de quatro
meninos pra uma menina nós vamos
entender isso um pouquinho lá na frente
e no brasil nós temos esse número não
mas a organização mundial da saúde ela
nos diz que 1% da população mundial têm
autismo esse número dá 76 milhões de
pessoas de famílias são afetadas pelo
autismo e no brasil esse número se nós
usarmos essa estimativa de 1%
ele teria o que no brasil nós temos
aproximadamente 2 milhões de famílias
afetadas pelo autismo
se eu perguntar pra vocês alguém aqui
conhece alguém com autismo ou tem na
família levanta anúncios favor quase a
totalidade isso relata
realmente o que a gente está vivendo
hoje o que é o transtorno do espectro do
autismo né o nome que é científico nome
que nós devemos usar como o próprio nome
diz é um espectro então é um transtorno
sócio comunicativo que vai desde pessoas
que não têm habilidade na linguagem
que têm interesses restritos tá certo
tem hiperfoco como pessoas que falam que
têm a linguagem que consegue se
desenvolver uma vida praticamente normal
mas não tem a comunicação social está
certo não tem uma habilidade de entender
dicas de entender piadas não tem uma
habilidade de ver o ambiente
ok então é hoje a gente tem que tirar um
pouco aquele estigma de achar que o
autista é aquele indivíduo que fica
quietinho não fala tem um movimento
repetitivo e não e que não olha não faz
contato não existem outros tipos de
autistas e nem pensar que só existe o
super gênios também não o autismo é um
espectro é muito variado e ele não tem
uma característica facial onde a gente
possa identificar
a gente tem que ter muito respeito e às
vezes essas características de
performance dos autistas pode ser algo
muito valioso até na riqueza de detalhes
existem autistas que fazem desenhos
maravilhosos com riquezas muito grande
de detalhes então a gente tem que
aproveitar as características que eles
têm positivas e trabalhar aqui eles não
têm pra que a gente tenha a indivíduos
cada dia melhores eo autismo quais são
as aos as causas do autismo
a gente sabe que existem fatores
genéticos e fatores ambientais
envolvidos no autismo
hoje o que nós temos é que existe uma
alta a herdabilidade no autismo esse
número é cerca de 70 a 90 por cento e os
fatores ambientais estão aí que
corroboram com os fatores genéticos
um dos fatores ambientais que a
literatura mais identifica como sendo
importante é a idade paterna
tá acima de 40 anos essa idade acaba
sendo algo bastante importante para o
autismo
e um outro fator bastante importante é o
ao uso de ácido valpróico um medicamento
anticonvulsivante e também no tratamento
é utilizado no tratamento de humor
quando utilizado na gestação
outros fatores como estresse é infecções
durante a gestação é é prematuridade
baixo peso no nascimento também são
fatores que a gente deve se levar em
conta mas ainda são objetos de estudos
só pra gente ter uma idéia os fatores
genéticos já estavam aí na sociedade há
bastante tempo porque o risco de quando
você tem gêmeos idênticos de você ter
autismo nas duas nos dois indivíduos é
de 80%
quando você tem gêmeos fraternos esse
risco é de 40% quando você já tem um
filho no autismo e você vai ter um
segundo filho esse risco é de 10 a 20%
sendo maior quando o primeiro filho é
uma menina e nós vamos entender isso
daqui a pouco e quando você já tem dois
filhos no espectro e vai ter um terceiro
esse risco aumenta um pouquinho pra 33%
antes de entrar na genética propriamente
dita vamos lembrar que nós somos
formados por células né
e no nosso genoma tá aonde no núcleo das
células e que nós temos ali no nosso
núcleo cromossomos são novelos
compactados de dna
esses novelos de compactados dna quando
nós descompactamos a gente vai ter
aquela sopinha de letras que a oaci hoje
eo t lembram disso da época da do
colégio da biologia básica uma sequência
determinada dessas letrinhas é um gene
tá e os genes eles são responsáveis por
dar origem às proteínas e as proteínas
são as que controlam aí todas as funções
do nosso orgulho do nosso organismo
se a gente imaginar ou fazer uma alusão
do nosso genoma como se fosse um livro
os cromossomos seriam os capítulos deste
livro e as frases seriam os genes
então eu estou falando isso só para a
gente entender o que é uma variante
genética
então vamos lá se eu trocar
se eu falar à televisão e ao invés de
falar à televisão falar pela revisão
vocês conseguem entender ainda o que é
sim
agora se eu fizer uma frase não me
imaginar que a frase é um gene e eu
falar hoje eu fiz um concerto e eu
trocar o s do concerto por um ser eu
voltar dizendo a mesma coisa
não eu vou estar mudando completamente o
sentido dessa frase é isso o que
acontece no nosso organismo quando a
gente tem uma alteração genética
dependendo da alteração genética você
vai mudar completamente o sentido ea
função daquilo que é o desempenho
daquela proteína ou daquela enzima enfim
é essa a conexão que eu quero fazer com
vocês é existem diversos tipos de
alterações genéticas
se eu fizer falar pra vocês que o gene
essa frase que a informação que o gene
carregue produz essa é a frase que a a
célula vai ter que produzir para
produzir uma proteína ok tá se eu trocar
o z da frase o s da frase por um z
vou ter mesmo sentido vôo
se eu mudar leva e realiza vou ter a
mesma coisa
vou também se eu tirar um verbo dessa
frase eu vou ter a mesma função não eu
vou afetar de alguma forma então a gente
disse não mudar a estrutura da frase se
ainda tem entendimento
que é uma variação da população
se a gente já causa uma troca que vai
trazer alguma alteração pode ser uma
doença
se você tem essas alterações ainda de
forma mais amena uma condição se você
tira pedaços inteiros dessa frase a
gente disse que pode ser uma síndrome e
voltando para o nosso então agora a
gente já sabe o que é uma alteração
genética vamos voltar então para o que
acontece no autismo
o autismo é uma condição multi genica e
multifatorial onde a gente usa um modelo
para explicar o autismo que o modelo de
copos onde o limite pra você ter autismo
não é a borda do copo e você tem
variantes comuns e variantes raras que
somadas levam esse indivíduo ao
transtorno do espectro do autismo como
também fatores ambientais
tá então como seria isso variantes
comuns variantes comuns que qualquer
pessoa que esteja aqui pode ter como que
funciona geralmente os pais não tenham
tista vão lá e tem um filho com autismo
então se vocês olharem no copo
a gente vai ter um pai com fatores
ambientais e uma variante comum a gente
vai ter a mãe com fatores ambientais ali
menores mas com uma variante rara e uma
variante comum
se você olhar no cope em baixo a gente
tem um filho a criança um tá certo
atingiu o limite atingiu sim e o que ela
tem ela tem uma variante herdada da mãe
uma variante rara
tá certo uma variante que não é comum
ela tem a variante comum do pai ea
variante comum da mãe e uma variante que
eu chamei de de que é uma variante
ovo que é uma alteração que aconteceu
que não foi herdada
aí você tem outras crianças que têm
outros tipos de variantes mas que não
atingiram limiar e a última criança você
tem atingindo limiar de novo né então
você tem uma alteração
ali o tamanho do círculo significa a
influência dessa variante pra quê pra
que o indivíduo tenha o autismo então
atingiu o limiar ou a criança 4 ela só
tem duas variantes uma variante rara
bastante importante e uma variante que
herdou da mãe tá então isso mostra para
nós que é uma somatória ea diferença que
eu falei que a gente entender um
pouquinho sobre a diferença entre
meninos e meninos é que é como se o copo
da mulher ele fosse maior do que o do
menino então isso explicaria o porquê a
gente tem mais meninos do que meninas e
explicaria por que é que o risco aumenta
quando nós temos o primeiro filho sendo
menina
ok e o que é importante para que nós
entendermos a genética de um indivíduo a
genética de um indivíduo ela pode trazer
a para que nós sabemos saibamos o que é
importante ea biologia desse indivíduo
nós podemos avaliar o risco de ter
outros indivíduos com autismo na família
nós podemos fazer o que a gente chama de
medicina personalizada é possível achar
variantes genéticas e associá-las a
medicamentos é possível estate ficar
pacientes isso é colocar pacientes que
tenham mesmo as variantes genéticas e
fazer estudos clínicos específicos
a medicina personalizada é algo bastante
atual que já vem acontecendo
a medicina principalmente pra para
câncer para tumores e hoje ela já também
está acontecendo para todas a toda a
parte neurológica então a forma como
genômica que é trazer essas variantes o
estudo dessas alterações genéticas e
correlacioná-los com medicamentos
além disso é existe um outro
procedimento chamado de modelagem de
doenças que é o que é você
a partir das células do paciente
você faz um processo chamado de
reprogramação celular que é o processo
de reprogramação celular
a grosso modo é como se você colocasse a
célula no túnel do tempo e você pegasse
uma célula adulta e virasse essa luta
virasse uma sala embrionária a célula
que tá ali durante na durante o
desenvolvimento embrionário na gestação
lei disse que o autismo é um transtorno
do neurodesenvolvimento as alterações
que acontecem o que ocorrem durante a
gestação
você fizesse essa célula então virar uma
sala embrionária a partir daí você
conseguir se formar neurônios
tá certo com as células do próprio
paciente carregando background genético
daquele paciente tornando neurônios o
que a gente chama de mini cérebros
a diferença entre os neurônios e os mini
cérebros é que os ministérios cérebro
são estruturas tridimensionais e é um
modelo que traz uma visão simplificada
da realidade é como se a gente colocasse
as células do paciente para fazer os
cérebros e fosse carregando toda a
genética daquele paciente com isso nós
criamos uma plataforma para screen de
drogas para a pesquisa de medicamentos
tá certo isso pode está associado com a
pesquisa genética que foi feita
anteriormente ou para a pesquisa
de forma aleatória isso já é uma
realidade nas universidades pra os
pacientes a realidade ainda é o
seqüenciamento genético mas acreditamos
que isso se tornará uma realidade muito
em breve mais uma palavra que eu
gostaria de dizer para todos vocês é que
não existe um autista igual ao outro a
genética mostra a cada dia mais isso
mas que independente de qualquer
diagnóstico de qualquer coisa que as
pessoas falem
a minha experiência é acreditem
acreditem porque eles podem muito mais
do que aquilo que a gente imagina
isso é o que eu queria falar pra vocês
obrigada
[Aplausos]